y let's go next to
let's go to Ty from Connecticut, Ty
from Connecticut. You're on the air.
How's it going? Good.
Yeah, Vienna sounds pretty nice right now.
Yeah, with that other place. My question is a
two parter. OK, and it's a little more abstract
than I think the other question been a little
more direct, a little more kind of in the weeds.
Do you think that Donald Trump. Is
an effective political communicator.
Well, see, here's what's very interesting,
Trump's statements, Trump's delivery is one
of the most incoherent I've ever heard from a
president and the sense that he will, you know,
make up words, say things that don't make
sense, say one thing and then say the opposite.
Never answer a question like
like analyzing it objectively.
He can barely put together a sentence if
you're if you're, like, logical and rational.
But at the same time, which is what I'm getting
at the same time, his his method of communication
has been hugely effective to the people that are
even likely to consider voting for him. Right. So
his method won't work for somebody who sees Trump
and says this is a grotesque, ignorant buffoon,
but for folks who are open to the
idea of being told, the reason
you don't make more money is because of China
and I will fix it or Mexico and I will fix it.
It it actually is effective. So so the answer it's
not there's not a clear cut answer. It depends on
who you're trying to appeal to.
Right, so the second part is,
and you can you can rearrange the question
how you want, but. I kind of want to try to
do a broader subject, which is, do you think sort
of the Democratic establishment, the the DNC,
Nancy Pelosi, Chuck Schumer, Barack Obama, Joe
Biden, Hillary Clinton, do you think that they
are effective political communicators? And
I'm going to actually add this, too. Yeah,
and you can you can answer
it however you want, but I.
Maybe you can even touch back on the Trump
thing, I think when I think of the question
like effective political communicator, I think
of like getting what they want done, whether
whatever what they want is I or you might
disagree with it. Do you think that they
are effective political communicators in that
way? And I'm just going to the reason why I'm
asking the question is I don't think they
are. And I suspect that you might. And I
I want to hear kind of your explanation why you do
honestly, of the people of the people you listed.
The only one that I think is really an effective
political character is Barack Obama. Yeah, right.
I mean, it's like Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer,
you know, they're in the positions they're in,
not because of being gifted speakers. They're in
the positions they're in because of being gifted
schmoozers and fundraisers and insiders.
As far as Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden,
you know, Joe Biden is not what he was at one
point, I think, in the late in the early 2000s.
And while he was vice president, I think Joe Biden
was quite an effective political communicator,
although he wasn't always in positions of of
that speech making as big of a difference.
But if the people you listed, Barack
Obama, is the one that really you know,
Bill Clinton in his heyday was a very effective
political communicator. And as you're saying,
this is aside from policy. But, no, the people
you listed mostly are not great communicators.
What then you have to consider as a whole
sort of the Democratic establishment I
look out of, is the Republican establishment
good political communicators? I'm not
sure maybe to their demographic. Yes, exactly.
I guess just to sort of round up the question,
the Democratic establishment
as a whole, if they want to,
you know, and this is this is kind
of where I get frustrated. Presumably
their agenda is not the Republicans
agenda. Right. So, I mean, you know, if.
If you have an agenda that's not the Republicans
agenda, are you effective at getting people to be
motivated to politically or there be a vote for
you or whatever, go vote in the Senate, whatever,
you know, are are you? And this is where I kind
of from the left get really concerned. And I think
that your comments have been actually rather
refreshing. But, yeah, as the establishment,
because I think this is where they need to
I think I think everyone thinks this and is
looking at this honestly, like, you know you know,
it's like a branding problem, I guess if you're.
Yeah. And listen, that's what we've you know,
check out my interview from who knows how long ago
with George Lakoff about this issue.
Like, I've not I've not hesitated to
to point this out. It's absolutely a problem.
Listen, I've got to run because I've got a
bunch of people to get to. I appreciate
the call. We're taking just a very,
very quick break. If you're holding on to
talk to me, don't hang up because they'll
be going right back to the phones momentarily.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.